wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
ja ok ins weißt du ich würde dich ab ich
freue mich auf das kann doch nicht wahr
sein
mogeln guten morgen sehen sie das ich
möchte nicht dass die mülltonne von
meinem laden steht wie oft soll ich das
noch sagen ich finde ja sie sollten sich
einfach mal entspannen
außer dem ball zu ihm weil ich habe
jetzt keine zeit für diskussion ich
bekomme besuch und muss eine
stadtbesichtigung planen da kann ich
ihnen vielleicht helfen und ihnen ein
paar tipps geben sie sollten auf jeden
fall das stadtschloss besuchen die
aktuelle dürer ausstellung ist wirklich
sehr schön
dank herr kleinen theater gibt es
außerdem ein neues programm ich bin
wirklich neugierig auf die faust
interpretation sie kennt of household
gegeben hat hier sehen sie ein kritiker
schreibt in der zeitung gehen
goethes faust begeisterte die
theaterbesucher gleich am ersten abend
ja es gab langen applaus die
schauspieler mussten drei mal wieder auf
die bühne kommen die gemälde aus dem
mittelalter im stadtmuseum die sind auch
ein echter geheimtipp
sehr schöne bilder das steht in keinem
staat aber entgehen sie bitte auf keinen
fall in das museum für moderne kunst das
nun sich kamps
[Musik]